do you have a Brendon impression let me
see um this is so Wow yeah you know you
just heard it obviously like brendan is
you good your sponsor life now I'm just
taking guy that's kind of mean no I
wasn't dressed bro did you look like 21
Jump Street you look how you got [ __ ]
up on 21st Avenue you look dude you look
like Lenny from of mice and Massimo yoga
guy that will not retire from Hot Topic
like the 50 year old did you locate the
50 year old vegan bro get your life
together man
you came back from Nashville and you
changed man what's with is Dog the
Bounty Hunter oh yeah Judy em look like
brothers
oh dude hey can you met your dad row
don't [ __ ] touch me he dyes his hair
dude and he has asthma too and he uses
the n-word we have a couple things in
common oh you guys look this wife looks
like a rockin yeah it's like her stomach
just [ __ ] hook to her chest and then
didn't got a divorce like what she eats
it just goes or did ya get a lot of
issues man
I have issues yeah you ever seen
yourself yeah you might be right
100% bro dude you know you're slowly
turning to [ __ ] I mean you're here
like that first is a mullet they just
have full-blown chicken oh this is
Swayze dude yeah it's Swayze
bro so many people stop and ask about
the hair and whatever's with the hair I
could be pushing like a senior citizen
in a wheelchair and I'm like oh who's
this [ __ ] yeah yeah anybody like what
are you even asking for like I saw the
hair and then just respected this old
person you know like the hair is a lot
of usually like you think joy cuz like I
think of like lesbian stepmom like a
little bit of a southern lesbian stepmom
did you have you told me well I don't
know what you hate on that I think dope
like I feel like if they're doing a
sitcom on ABC and you walked in on a
dress they're like this your new stepmom
and be like oh that's just it'll cure
Down syndrome bruh I beat it
there's a lot of rumors in my town I got
beat down syndrome
yeah well that's inspiring man that's
how I thought when I heard him because I
didn't start them and that's one of the
things that's beautiful about sometimes
being in a small town is you know it
doesn't take long for you to hear [ __ ]
about yourself yeah you get more
feedback yeah in LA some guy walks
through by in the hall like aw look at
this [ __ ] chimpanzee you know but you
never know you never hear but in a small
towns only nine people I know we hear it
now though these days social media yeah
they get you you get a lot of haters on
there I'm sure I'm sure I don't see a
lot of it but I'm sure do you um I don't
think so I mean I get I get some stuff I
guess
but I don't think anything I really
trying to think of something I'm tough
to hate on you cuz you're not really
like I'll get like I'll get some hate
obviously what am i you're easier to
hate it well you think I mean there's
just more I mean not in like a if I know
you know but if I to see you dude
welcome pop more than you you look like
a mechanic from Knorr from rat
[Laughter]
you look bro you let me think about
exactly what you look like dude bro look
at you dude you look like a do that eats
burgers and just carries around a
[ __ ] shotgun look hol have you seen
some of you guys are probably listening
on radio you can't see this man on ham
radio to brace corner would race quarter
woodchuck [ __ ] me
you look like you were that orange juice
and [ __ ] never touch the kid and I have
worked at a smoothie place you know I
would never do anything wild to a kid
and I babysat overnight three times
dude I would not let you babysit my kids
well that's this is real friendship
Brian and Brendan's you guys look like
the cou this is America bro
[ __ ] you're in black you're in black
what do you got some Egyptians from Long
Island we're in 19 different colors hey
you got a bouncer at a TGI Fridays and
be confident
you look like the Patrick Swayze without
the pancreatic cancer look at Nick Sam
look at Nick's [ __ ] socks look at the
collar me clothes like you robbed a hot
powerful Brian like your rosacea like
the toughest [ __ ] at a Claire's
boutique dude [ __ ] busboy you inject
each other on the silo highway then [ __ ]
each other we're just supposed to
breathe like it's normal
just go dude in the south on the side of
a New Orleans highway sucking each other
off
Oh gir that it took you look I get an
eight-year-old boy got an infection from
an ogre and drinks keels at the airport
do you look troubled
you drink some more bottles of Kiehl's
hand lotion at the airport you got
issues man
Oh
mock up a decent image of this you look
like Lenny from Of Mice and Men but if
we're filmed in like like if it were
filmed probably more film they look like
the biggest [ __ ] kid in Sacramento
fro and that's true dude and I mean them
and I don't mean that in a mean way like
Macho Man Randy Savage we had AIDS man
Randy tragic no
the war if he just hugged it out no heat
shirt in it what you do what you told me
you look like him if you were in the
second a man your baton Swiss dude dude
you look like Lenny from of mice and
Massimo closing I know to a Russian
probably you or you know he's way more
Russian looking than I am that's Western
Europe you don't look Iranian bro dude
you don't look American out of me but
you look bad bro Brian looks the most
[ __ ] Russian you look Eastern
European I'm eating little I do you like
soup yet I mean no FINA yet see no
brother I electric right now this whole
couch is shaking it's don't touch me
dude and it's the third time it's
happening here dude five times dude I'm
calling the police
hold yelling shave your head dude I look
I grew up in the molester Belt five
times he touched me I'm calling the cops
five I'm sorry about if I would give you
a couple of I'm saying you have women's
band-aids on the back here for you these
are major band-aid much younger more
handsome a little bit of a southern
twang and a mullet who made a talent
yeah this isn't a mullet first of all
gender-neutral haircut it's the only way
I'm getting work these days with this
haircut bro you know and you look I
don't know what you'd call mine you know
I got my hair cut in San Jose and it
might like this old-school like gangster
dude he goes bro you look like John
Gotti now well I don't know if that's
the look I'm going for Matt murderers
cut yeah he goes he goes everyone wants
to do it because I always get a fade you
know I get faded up usually high and
tight yeah and he goes not so what the
kids are doing man you let me do a plant
camo dude this is your camo wookie
these are enough camo capris on these
aren't jeans capris on they was some
with some Under Armour shoes with nike
socks
camo women capris and a woman's hair
what [ __ ] row you have a
you can only get from being a cafeteria
female cafeteria worker who's abusing
steroids you lately on the job you broke
you look like you make sloppy joes
there's me like that you look like you
make the best sloppy joe in LA right now
you look like you raised two kids named
sloppy joe dude if you [ __ ] lose both
you lasted two girls named Diane what
are you talking about dude I'm growing
this for a kid dude when you see my back
I pull myself up like a champ
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gift it's a gift
it's a gift